cómo
por favor
buenos días a todos yo quiero hablar hoy
de lo que es la innovación represento a
13m una de las compañías más innovadoras
del mundo pero quiero hablar de lo
simple que es la innovación
ustedes dirán la innovación es para
empresas super grandes para países
superdesarrollados y la respuesta es no
a través de contarles la historia
nuestra lo sencilla que es yo quiero
incentivarlos a todos ustedes a que
piensen en innovación como la innovación
va a mejorar la vida de ustedes la vida
de los que los rodea la vida sus
empresas y sobre todo cómo podemos
contribuir al desarrollo de este lindo
país que es méxico
sólo una pequeña semblanza para
comentarles todos los problemas que
nosotros tenemos con los consultores y
todos los problemas que tenemos con los
analistas de wall street cuando ellos
ven cómo está compuesta nuestra empresa
nuestra empresa es de cinco grupos de
negocios todos totalmente diferentes
tenemos 55 mil productos en industria en
seguridad para proteger a las personas
cuando
gráficos señales reflectivas
electrónicos y energía cuidado de la
salud y consumo y se dirán cómo una
empresa puede tener tantos productos
totalmente diferentes y ahí donde los
consultores dicen dedícate zapatero a
tus zapatos los de bolsos dicen porque
no te enfocas a un solo negocio y partes
la empresa en cinco la respuesta es no
nuestro foco esta innovación esta
tecnología de una forma muy sencilla de
ver la tecnología y es lo que yo les
quiero comentar
yo estudié programación de computadoras
estudia administración de empresas y
siempre tuvo un problema con la química
la química no me gustaba para nada pero
entonces cuando salí de la universidad
de sevilla por fin nunca más podría
poder voy a tener que ver química error
verdad nuestra empresa usa la tabla
periódica de los elementos para poner
sus tecnologías esto no son los
elementos sino que son las diferentes
tecnologías que tiene la empresa y
combinando esas 546 plataformas
tecnológicas
es que formamos 55.000 productos y yo
les voy a enseñar cómo es esto de simple
igual los puede incentivar a que ustedes
piensen como la innovación que es la que
produce desarrollo riqueza y progreso
para los países es muy simple entonces
estas son nuestras 46 plataformas
tecnológicas una de ellas por ejemplo es
adhesivos
nosotros inventamos los adhesivos hace
muchos años y de los adhesivos sacamos
más de la mitad de nuestros productos
por ejemplo tenemos adhesivos para
electrónicos y energía todos los cómo se
unen cómo se pegan y se ensamblan los
teléfonos es con adhesivos que conducen
energía ya no se usan tornillos para que
sean más delgados los films tal vez
usted no se acordarán pero nosotros
teníamos las transparencias los lectores
de transparencias hay gente que me dice
que si ver a los alumnos nuevos creo que
no pero esta misma tecnología con un
adhesivo se le pone a los teléfonos y
refleja la luz tal como lo hacían hace
50 años para que su teléfono
hasta la mitad perdón una tercera parte
de la batería en industria para pegar
las partes de los automóviles quién va a
viajar por avión hoy alguien tiene un
viaje hoy no qué bueno
porque las alas de los aviones para que
sepan son pegadas con cinta era una
cinta que amortigua que no son remaches
verdad que viene de los adhesivos que
inventamos especial que tiene un vuelo
mañana no importa porque hace le salga
haber olvidado que las alas de los
aviones son pegadas con adhesivos y ahí
puedo decir las cintas médicas que
ustedes usan en el hospital o cuando
tienen heridas adhesivos los gráficos
las señales reflectivas llevan adhesivos
para ser pegadas y las notas
autoadhesivas o las cintas son así
entonces se entiende y se va a ver más
fácil cuando veamos la historia de
innovación de la compañía una tecnología
adhesivos nos sirve para estar en
electrónica industria en cuidados de la
salud en seguridad etcétera
combinando esas tecnologías por ejemplo
veremos las películas solares
las películas solares que usamos en las
grandes ventanas en los edificios
bien para que reflejen los ultravioletas
y se gaste menos aire acondicionado y se
protejan sus muebles
estos son cintas adhesivas muy grandes
con adhesivos que se juntan con films
que se juntan con el manejo de la luz
formamos las películas solares y los
apósitos médicos que estamos son
hospitales y se usa fin sus adhesivos la
misma tecnología para otro producto o
los dientes antes los que vamos al
dentista decíamos el que quiere plata
oro que hay en esos colores súper feos
hoy va a una dentista y le dicen qué
color es su diente para ser un adhesivo
igual esa nanotecnología que es una
tecnología de 3m adhesivos cerámicas
etcétera entonces combinando esas
tecnologías que yo les mostraba aquí
verá es donde formamos los 55 mil
productos
como puede beneficiar eso a ustedes yo
le va hablar de la historia de
innovación de nuestra compañía y también
les voy a hablar de nuestro adán y eva
como algo muy simple ha llevado a
producir a generar una de las compañías
más innovadoras que tenemos en el mundo
quién conoce esto es una lija
y una lija es un papel es un adhesivo y
son minerales que pasas este producto
que es nuestro adam básicamente le
quitamos el mineral que se forma
es lo mismo antes de ver cómo de simple
pasamos de un negocio que es para lijar
muebles para lijar metales pasamos a la
industria pasamos al negocio de pintura
qué pasa si usted a este producto que es
una lija sin mineral le cambia en lugar
de papel le pone un frío qué pasa usted
entra ahora a sellar cajas
el negocio de empaque entra a otras
áreas de la industria pero qué pasa si
éste esto también lo hacemos más pequeño
entramos a su hogar y quiero que
recuerden esto porque gracias a la lija
que le quitamos el el mineral lo hicimos
más pequeño entramos a su hogar para que
ustedes usan la cinta adhesiva scotch en
su hogar para empacar regalos verá cómo
entramos regalos entramos ahora
desarrollamos un moño y lo que me
interesa el moño es que es un material
no tejido que es muy sencillo me encanta
este mono by the way entonces usted van
a ver como como pusimos fibras juntas
para que se vieran bonitos
vimos que esto dejaba pasar el aire
yahyá yahyá va a ser ya ya van a ver
porque voy a usar a esto verá todos han
visto que cuando se manejan que qué es
esto
una señal efectiva esto en realidad que
salva muchas vidas todos los días esto
en realidad es una lija es una lija que
en lugar de ponerle minerales que raptan
le pusimos microesferas de vidrio que
son espejos entonces refleja la luz y
eso es que por lo cual son muy
brillantes entonces cuando ustedes vayan
por la autopista está lloviendo una
avenida etcétera y hay una señal de alto
y ustedes paren ustedes puede decir
gracias lija por salvarme la vida
entonces se entiende que como como la
cultura apropiada de innovación puede
llevar a una creatividad ilimitada que
pasa así a esto pero ustedes le cambian
el respaldo y lo hacen de vinil ustedes
entran la cinta aislante y entran a otra
industria entonces por eso es que
nuestra compañía está en todas las
industrias la misma tecnología de la
lija que es nuestro a adam la misma
tecnología de la cinta que es nuestra
eva usted la va modificando y va creando
e hijos nuevos no usted no se cuadran
muchos de ustedes pero en nuestra
compañía inventó la cinta magnética verá
que le pusimos en lugar de ponerle
adhesivo le pusimos plata y si son
material magnético que servía para
grabar después inventamos las cintas de
vídeo que ha visto esto que ha visto
esto
una esponja quiero ver cuántos hombres
levantan la mano por favor no no va a
quedar mal alguien quien lava los platos
en su casa está esta esponja que es lo
mismo que sirve para lavar los platos
que deja pasar el agua es lo mismo que
el moño que yo les comenté que inventó
el semen porque es lo mismo aquí es un
material tejido que deja pasar el aire
aquí es un material tejido que deja
pasar el agua entonces como la misma
tecnología ustedes la van uniendo y van
creando nuevos productos lo mismo pasó
con las cintas médicas
que vienen de la industria decimos
hipoalergénicas la hicimos con material
no tejido y este creamos las cintas
médicas y así las películas solares los
archivos dentales que ya hablé hoy
quiero hablar de uno de los productos
más exitosos de la compañía quien conoce
esto
es un respirador que esté salva la vida
qué pasó
bernardo vengo aquí a dar una plática y
tú contesta a una llamada por favor dame
el teléfono
el tipo contestó una llamada y sabe lo
que hago en 13 m cuando alguien no pone
su teléfono en silencio sabe lo que hago
no se preocupen aquí estamos fingiendo
con bernardo el teléfono de verdad sigue
funcionando ustedes lo pueden ver el
teléfono de verdad no sigue funcionando
y es para explicar lo sencillo que es la
tecnología porque porque en nuestra
compañía sigue funcionando sigue sonando
desde luego verán lo sencillo que es la
tecnología la compañía inventó un
limpiador de contactos para teclados de
computadoras y vimos que era al final un
agua que no mojaba entonces eso lo
pasamos a para extinguir incendios en
productos para extinguir incendios
cuando hay un incendio se se roza o se
riega con este producto y básicamente es
el agua que no moja las obras de arte
son protegidas con el agua que no moja
si alguien tiene que tiene un billete un
billete por favor un billete
de 500 por favor
de 50 bueno ánimo
usted puede meter lo que quiera lo que
quiera y no se va a dañar nada entonces
como de inventar un limpiador de
contactos nosotros pasamos a inventar
algo que protege las obras de arte que
protege las computadoras sumergimos
computadoras para que gasten menos
energía y produzcan
menos calor pero no volvamos nuestro
tema esto esto que fue para limpiar
platos ahora sirve para proteger a las
personas lo que deja pasar el agua aquí
deja pasar el aire aquí pero no crea que
pasamos directo no crea que pasamos
directos sino que cuando en los años 50
las mujeres estaban vestidos ver ahí
usaban brassieres
eso producía mucho calor entonces tres
elementos los brassieres que dejaba
pasar el aire
entonces las mujeres todas se veían muy
bonitas se vean iguales y el aire
podía pasar pasar podía respirar yo
siempre digo que alguien con él
es mucha con mucha innovación e
imaginación dijo bueno porque no lo
ponemos aquí y es
se hizo para que las personas podrían
respirar ahora es el producto de mayor
venta de 3m en el mundo entonces como de
una esponja usted pasa de un moño usted
pasa una esponja usted pasa a un
respirador y para terminar mi historia
verá hablamos de los respiradores
hablamos de las notas autoadhesivas que
ustedes conocen se acuerdan el archivo
de la línea se acuerdan el archivo de
los states
son adhesivos muy muy simples que se han
ido modificando y inventamos uno tan
malo para que ustedes lo reconocerán un
adhesivo tan malo que se despegan pero
también dependiendo del ángulo que usted
lo ocupe puede ser muy resistente
entonces cuando usted tiene un expertise
ustedes realmente experto en adhesión
usted puede crear productos que sean
buenos ese mismo año que inventamos este
producto
inventamos la cinta que llamamos
de muy alto pegado de beihai ponte que
es la que se ocupa para pegar las alas
de los aviones el mismo año inventamos
el archivo más malo y el archivo más
bueno era cuando le mandamos las cintas
herboso a embraer a boeing nos
aseguramos que sea la cinta correcta y
no lo estemos mandando
el porcino algo que sería un poquito
entonces y así yo les puedo seguir
contando como de ir uniendo tecnologías
ir desarrollando usted crea una de las
empresas más exitosas del mundo pero no
solamente es la tecnología y ese es mi
único mi último punto que quiero
remarcar en mi última transparencia en
los tres minutos que me quedan lo que
usted también necesita es una cultura de
innovación ahora yo le expliqué como de
una lija sale una gran corporación pero
también es la cultura de innovación que
no fue difundida desde que la compañía
nació y básicamente lo que nosotros
decimos los principios de william
mcknight y esto ojalá le sirva a ustedes
contrate buenos empleados
y déjelos en paz que ellos puedan dar
como ver nada porque hacer todos muy
bien poner aquí en su teléfono era
déjenlos en paz de los crear si tenemos
una base donde podemos hacer inventar o
hacer imaginación las cosas van a
funcionar motive a los empleados a
ejercer su iniciativa eso es vital para
que la gente no tenga cercos que la
gente pueda crear déjelos ejecutar su
trabajo a su manera y la gerencia que es
destructiva crítica destructiva mente
crítica frente a los errores mata a la
iniciativa entonces esos principios son
los que hemos aplicado deje a la gente
libre no mate la iniciativa y aprenda de
sus errores entonces y eso les quería
comentar como una compañía de mucha
tecnología ha salido de algo muy simple
y de combinar esas tecnologías y de
dejar que la gente cree es más yo le voy
a contar una historia personal para
terminar que fue yo cometí un gran error
entres en un error muy muy grave verdad
que fue cuando yo estaba empezando en la
compañía en el salvador
y ahora gerente de finanzas y también el
general y teníamos un gerente de ventas
entonces siempre teníamos la discusión
que cuando se contratarán personas los
dos teníamos que aprobar a qué personas
se contrataban entonces yo me di cuenta
que le empezó a contratar chicas jóvenes
y todas muy bonitas
y decía sí está bien pero también nos
gustaría que contratáramos personas
mujeres con experiencia que han estado
en la calle que puedan ir a ver clientes
que hayan vivido el proceso de venta
etcétera pero bueno el contrato una
chica muy bonita también contrato la
segunda chica muy bonita está bien
la tercera oye bueno también la cuarta
vera yo le dije mira ya vi que están
entrevistando está chica muy bonita
queremos mujeres con más experiencia y
no las contrates porque porque va a ir a
donde un cliente intenté decir que no va
a servir y llorando no sé qué no sé
cuánto queremos gente con experiencia no
las contratas y me dijo el muy tarde ya
la contraten
no puede ser ya vas a ver el error que
cometiste ya saber que gracias a hacer
eso no va a vender nada y va a regresar
llorando la oficina gran error primero
se hizo la mejor vendedora de la
compañía a los pocos tiempos esa persona
se ha convertido en la mejor supervisora
y promovida a gerente de mercadeo en muy
rápido
ahí comprendí mi error pero lo más lo
más interesante es que después de ser
una carrera muy exitosa en muy corto
tiempo la mejor vendedora la mejor
supervisora la mejor gerente esa chica
pero hoy es mi esposa entonces hay
errores que uno puede hacer pero lo
puede remediar así que
muchísimas gracias y ahora está de
salida
[Aplausos]